and we have the story from cbs austin
arrest made an arson incident at travis
county democratic party office they say
a molotov cocktail was thrown inside the
office and ignited during the early
morning of early early morning hours so
earlier i was wrong i thought it didn't
but it didn't the arson suspect was
recorded on security cameras and a note
was left at the scene the austin fire
department says there are some
investigators along with the fbi made
the arrest ryan faircloth 30 is charged
with second degree felony arson and
third degree felony possession of a
prohibited weapon he remains in custody
at travis county jail under a combined
40 000 bond for both charges
early wednesday morning outside an
outside camera recording a man throwing
a rock through the front door
of the democratic party office he then
came back with what appears to be an
incendiary device placed it inside the
building and then uh the fire ignited
damage to the building was minimized
because people at the bar across the
street spotted the first flames and put
them out with a fire extinguisher last
year vandals hit the same building
spraying graffiti across the front
that's when security cameras were
installed that may help police find who
was responsible for the latest damage
we were talking about the other day
you know related to this what happens if
texas secedes or new hampshire and one
of the things i was saying that you know
i guess people hadn't considered is what
do the democrats in austin do if the
republicans in texas say we're out right
you can already see there's conflict
between
cultural factions that's how new york is
i mean most of new york voted red a lot
of new york and the city controls most
of it so it's like when you talk about
secession what does something like new
york city do you were there right you
lived in new york city yeah i was
driving a box truck for
riots uh not the riots but like leading
up to the to the 2016 election so i
would see like um all the signs for
hillary in one place and all the trump
signs and the rest of you know upstate
new york not that that should be a gauge
of how people are going to vote but it
was wild to see that yeah all of upstate
new york is one way it's so weird
but maybe it's because people in the
cities are scared they're scared to say
anything country versus city true if you
put up a trump sign in an area where
there's 50
hillary's
hillary's i said hillary by the way
but i that's a real saliva
thanks chris
yeah that it's i mean maybe dangerous
isn't the word but maybe it is and
that's the problem with it that's why we
have secret voting you know that's why
you you're voting as anonymous yes
i wonder so we
we did talk about texas and for those
who don't understand uh know the context
of the last episode you know we had we
had someone from the freestate project
in new hampshire new hamp there's a lot
of people in new hampshire who want to
secede or form their own you know nation
state or whatever
and like a lot a lot of people say
things you know if texas can't it won't
happen
but there's also the conversation we've
had where it's like the federal
government wouldn't do anything so look
at california california says outright
we no longer will allow the feds to
enforce immigration law actually
stopping them and that's a state saying
the federal government has no authority
here in this regard and the feds say
okay that's it the emperor's got no
clothes the moment california was able
to say this the moment cities in
california were allowed to
were allowed to let non-citizens vote
the federal government lost legitimacy
because they couldn't enforce their own
laws within the country
that's going to set up a cascade effect
but the interesting thing is what
happens in a state like texas if texas
succeeds the belief is the feds won't do
anything but what happens when the
democrats in austin call for help the
feds then nationalize the national guard
in neighboring states and send them into
texas to protect you know the law and
law and order
that being said that's the context
here's the next question
if that does happen and the government
does nationalize or federalize the
national guard
from new york for instance what will the
majority of the new york state
republicans in all like northern part
say to the city you know because they're
the people who are in the national guard
in that place probably come from some
rural areas from the city from all over
and a lot of them are going to be rural
and now working at the behest of i think
we could just see like conflict chaos
politically
they don't have much power the red the
red part of new york and it's almost
like new york city has already seceded
from the rest of the state because
they've locked out not to say that
everyone who's red
has not been vaccinated but if you're
not vaccinated you're not allowed in
that city anymore can't do anything i
have a friend
went to eight different bars in the past
two days turned away wow all of them
went to her favorite cafe told i will
serve you if you sit out outside yeah
out there that's what they said when i
called so they've locked out everybody
else i i don't know how much political
they have i don't even know if they care
about the city they act like it's not
there that's a good point we didn't even
talk about new york city has basically
already said yeah these people are not
welcome here
and that's a large portion i think half
of republicans are not vaccinated yeah
that means like
straight up
trump supporters the staunch supporters
of trump are completely cut off from new
york city and los angeles and new
orleans and san francisco all of these
cities that are rolling this out no zoos
this is a session there's no restaurants
yeah they've they've manufactured it in
a way where it's not you don't have to
say succession the way they've kicked
you out the weird part is like back in
the day you'd have a city block would
secede from another city block it'd be
territory but now it's kind of ideology
like
too many people live close together that
have different ideologies so you can't
you know like you said the big city
in texas is democrat but all the
surrounding areas is republican so
i think rather than a succession which
would be like shattering a crystal
crystalline form structure you would
have to somehow alter the way they
interact which this these coded
restrictions seem to be doing yeah and i
should also say that there's a lot of
people in new york city who are also
either vaccinated and against the
mandates or not vaccinated doesn't mean
they're red or blue but they're fighting
like i know people who are working in
sanitation who are fighting really hard
to keep their jobs you know this is
interesting we didn't even consider this
when having these conversations about
secession that there could be people
whose secret intention is the breakup of
the u.s and they do it through laws they
know are partisan that will result in a
soft secession meaning new york city has
basically said maga not welcome no i've
been listening to alex alex jones did uh
he was on sydney and elijah's show and
then he went on uh gosh what did he go
about her yeah he went on crowder and
they were taught i watched a little bit
of that and i was fact checking what he
was talking about and klaus schwab
really i mean since
for decades he's been intending to make
like a corporate global organization
governments aren't effective enough we
need corporations to work with
governments to govern the world now
pretty sure that's like mussolini's
fascism definitely it's fascism when you
when you collude corporations and
governments but i think that there's
this outside foreign entity that's doing
this to the united states because the
united states is very very unique and we
need to preserve it in my opinion but
other forces that doesn't register with
klaus he's not an american he never was
so it's a foreign concept to him what we
have here well you heard what jack
dorsey said
you know it's a cliche to bring up the
dorsey podcast with rogan that we did
but
jack said we are working we we care to a
global audience not an american one and
right there it's like okay
he is telling us that their intention is
to subvert the american will that he
doesn't view the nation as even existing
on top of that you have people like
bernie sanders
he he tweeted out which two senators
should not be able to stop 48 senators
and 210 congressmen and women
it's like senator sanders there's 52
senators in opposition to you but he
doesn't view the other half of the
country as being part of the equation
so he's outright like you are not a part
of this
and then you you take a look at how big
tech acts
it feels like
it's funny when we have that we had some
guy super chat saying that you know we
we on this show and the friends of this
show are radicalized and i'm like
we are the ones who are like america
american history
constitution liberty that's not
radicalizing that's status quo that's
being like this country is about
defending civil rights
granting them over time and protecting
the individual now we have a growing
faction of
internationalists and they say they are
authoritarians and they say that well
they lie about that because they don't
want to admit it but they show us they
are and it feels like
perhaps we get this wrong we talk about
the culture war and we say left versus
right or authoritarian versus
libertarian it is the soul of america
versus the conquering forces which are
destroying it and the conquering forces
make up tens of millions and are be and
control the institutions i think the
idea of saying the greater good has
accelerated the idea of of like this
global community like i care for
everybody but people who are saying
great or good lately they're also
telling me that they don't believe in
things like borders
and so
america doesn't it's an idea now it
doesn't exist right it's everybody else
outside um which we should all care
about people but
they've erased the borders
i think people need to understand
there's not going to be
like
any kind of
internationalism i mean that's what the
left literally calls they don't call it
globalism right will not
actually happen they don't they don't
understand that they are selling
themselves out these american leftists
who are like i believe in
internationalism and it's like okay what
will really happen is that the global
powerful elites with with powerful
military forces will just centralize
their authority in their own country and
everyone else will be subjugated it's
not going to be like a one-world
government it's going to be the hunger
games with capital city that they live
in well-guarded and protected and then
you will lose everything and you'll be
happy so they say even more terrifying
is it's they don't even care about the
government's half the time it's the
corporations that they want to govern
like
it makes sense corporations can function
like authoritarian machines they can
distribute resources um at their own
whims and they can shut you off if they
want you know socially they'll erase you
it's incredible how someone can get
banned off of all these social media
networks and then have their bank
account shut down by paypal and visa and
like all at once like within a day it
can happen to someone that's in
completely i mean not i don't like the
word anti-american but i mean it's the
antithesis of of like of individual
freedom and liberty like we're supposed
to create a government to protect our
ability to communicate and socialize
you know what i'll say this if america
cannot survive this it doesn't deserve
to
if america does not have the the resolve
the strength the will and the fortitude
to survive the authoritarianism that
it's sweeping across this country then
then it should one thing that could
happen is it could take over this thing
and then it's like we're under another
corporate monarchy for the next x amount
of years and then there's another
revolution or we can resist it and avoid
that tyranny
at what point do they start actually
resisting
there this is a form of resistance just
by talking about them pointing out like
yeah hey klaus shaw wants to have
corporations govern you right that's
that's a form of resistance and i don't
think the pressure will ever stop yeah
that's the thing when do we when do we
stop resisting i guess the censorship is
my biggest problem when it comes to like
erasing voices i think
people should be able to say what they
want and we could debate that and you
know i i always talk about the immune
system of your ideas can only get better
if you put it out there to fight
something that you might not believe in
but you hear an idea maybe it makes your
idea stronger or you learn you were
wrong right if you censor all these
voices you don't have that anymore then
you're just in a corner and you can only
say one thing and then ideas stop
growing well then the powerful elites
can say what they want yeah and that's
what will happen for sure and that's and
that's what it means to have corporate
rules great advertising you know
corporate rule me it's it's it's
you know honestly it is communism
and it's not it's like it's like
neo-futuristic communism they don't
take over by force
they take over by selling you things you
like they take over by convincing you to
give up your rights and then eventually
there's a corporation
with a chairman
and they can decide
you have to do x if you want access to
why you if you want food then you work
for us oh it's a private company we can
do what we want
so when
court when when corporation x is more
powerful than the government
and the government can't protect its
people the government and the
corporation controls where you can go
and what you can say and they do in many
ways then eventually you are just a part
of an authoritarian dictatorship i don't
care what you call it corporations don't
grant you the same
you know don't protect your rights they
don't care you work for a fast food
restaurant they can ask you at any
moment now there are some laws in the
public side to protect you but the
public side is just they're they're
they're they're colluding together and
if you think you have job security at a
corporation wait till they automate your
role and want to cut back on their
overhead and then you don't have really
any job security there's nothing not
that you have job security by nature but
it's not going to like enhance your
ability to work working for a
corporation as opposed to government
yeah people aren't working i drove down
here i saw a pen i saw panera somewhere
they were they were closed under staffed
sign on the door sorry i've been in this
pen and it's one like a ton of times on
the way down it's cascade failure man
yeah when when one store has 10 people
working and that's their and they're
like slightly above the staff they need
for operation and then one person says
i quit i don't want to do this anymore
or i have to move my family's moving
because of coving right now they're down
to nine people and they're like okay now
we're pushing it everyone's working a
little bit more than they'd like to but
we can maintain this and then someone
goes i didn't sign up for this i don't
get paid enough i quit now they're
understaffed then the people are just
like dude i can't work 60 hours i need a
day off i quit and then there's no one
left and they say with only five people
we can't keep this place open i'm sorry
guys have a nice day you're all fired so
it's the death of the smaller businesses
people don't want to work but they
worship corporations
and the country will become the
corporation
it's happening it's going to be like
idiocracy with costco thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you